[Music]
man and I'm starving anything edible
over there like a buffalo chicken pizza
nah just squirrel poops ah no I can't
eat no more of that [__] you know what
that goes right through me hey I think I
got something
what do you got
what are those kind of looks like food I
don't I don't know
look at that oh it's not too bad I'm
down the clown how many of these should
we eat all of them yeah that makes sense
this is so good oh this one's spicy I'm
kind of nutty right
all right ah that should hold this solid
dinner
all right let's get moving oh [__] uh
give me a second whoa whoa what the [__]
[Music]
[Applause]
oh yeah yeah I know I should probably
take it off no no it's growing oh my God
oh my God
can be
tomorrow
hello bud
what are you doing out here we need to
talk wait mag you look different really
oh [__] you look different too how so
um you're kinda is it my human hands
[Applause]
today is gonna be the best day ever I
love sunshine I love butterflies but
more than anything I love Doug hey
shut the [__] up [__] piece of [__]
that's Doug the best owner in the world
we're playing this game called fetching
Fox [__] he drops me off really far
away and drives home without me when I
bring the ball back he says [__] that's
how I know I won the game
hey honey you ever been with an Afghan
before I don't think so what thank you
thank you for me kid he left your ass oh
that can't be right you are officially
astray that would mean
tuck doesn't love me poor little guy I
should probably talk to him I am a
therapy dog Fred you can learn how
beautiful he conceived when you're off
the leash this beer is making me dizzy
he's about to get real Dizzy up in this
[__] I'm having a great time
with the [__] home perm and
[__] what did you just say I really hate
for this to get violence you were
straight you can do anything you want
I'm going back to Doug's what the [__]
man he needs to pay for what he did with
the only thing he truly loves I'm gonna
bite his dick off
[Music]
even under these strange circumstances
lost and my little puppy paw pads are
really hurting right now so
oh my God
oh
[__] guys we've got a dick to Ripper
what are those kind of looks like food
oh [__] uh give me a second you look
different [__] you look different too
how so is it my human hands
[Music]